foreign
show is well you know it doesn't matter
what the topic is that caller is calling
in in that moment going I I need some
help and it's so funny it's like hey my
name is Tom how much do you make and how
much debt you got I mean we're like
right through it man we'll celebrate
with you the things no one else will
celebrate may or may not like us or you
may not or may not agree with us but
what we say is simple oh it's doable and
it's life-changing hey I'm George
Campbell and I want to help people spend
less save more so they can live a life
with more freedom basically I want to
help people suck less with money hey my
name is Ken Coleman and I help men and
women discover and do the work that they
were created to do hey guys I'm Rachel
Cruz and I love helping people get in
control of their money and create a life
that they love hey what's up my name is
John deloney I sit with people who are
struggling to figure out the next right
step for them hi I'm Christina Ellis I
love to help people figure out how to
pay for their education's debt free and
win with money hey I'm Dave Ramsey I've
spent the last 30 years of my life
helping people get out of debt become
wealthy and become outrageously generous
so we're here celebrating 30 years of
the Ramsey Show Dave you've had a lot of
success over the years best-selling
author many times over over 600 radio
Affiliates 18 million listeners three
hours of radio for 30 years are you
tired
I'm fine okay life is good well take us
back because it's easy to forget that it
didn't start this massive and this big
headquarters and Big Shows and all these
team members take us back to where it
started well there was a
a radio station in Nashville that was in
bankruptcy
and um
I went on a friend of mine that was a
real estate guy had a show
that was pretty much like a bad Saturday
Night Live skit like bad talk radio
that's if you did a Saturday night
that's what it looked like only he was
serious about it it was just bad and
they had no Staffing they were in
bankruptcy so he answered his own phones
and um live on the air and no screening
how does that work uh not well but um
so anyway I went on the show and we were
talking about real estate and I had this
we were in this Real Estate club and
trying to get people to come visit the
club with the speaker coming to town and
that kind of thing and and then towards
the end of it he goes so uh you know uh
what are you doing these days I said
well I'm helping people that have you
know had trouble financially and he goes
well if you've had trouble financially
just call in right now and if you're
struggling and the phone rang and he
wasn't used to the phone ringing much
and kind of scared him and so he's like
uh you're on the air and some guy whose
car was in repo and was crying and right
there and she'll be answering the call
and then somebody else called and we
answered the question and and he wasn't
used to getting that kind of action on
the air it was because it was bad and he
goes hey man come back let's do this
again that kind of worked and I went
okay so I did it a couple more times and
then a a friend of mine in the mutual
fund business at the time uh called me
and said uh the guy that you were on the
show quit they're paying him 35 a day or
something and his check didn't clear in
bankruptcy and he goes we got to go do
that show and I went I'm not doing radio
radio people don't get paid nothing
they're like Bankers big Egos and titles
and no money I need money I am broke my
kids are hungry I'm not doing this he
goes hey man we gotta go do that show he
goes you could do it a couple days a
week I could do it a couple days a week
I'd get leads from a mutual fund
business and who knows you might even
sell some of that stupid little book you
wrote
and that was Financial Peace that was
Financial Peace carrying it around the
trunk of my car Wow real so nervous like
I can only imagine not doing anything
like now you're used to like right
radio and all of that yeah oh we were
and we were bad were you nervous though
yeah but we were bad
it was it was awful did you know you're
awful yeah yeah no y'all probably
thought you were great well I mean
there's part of you but I mean we were
we were cheesy but we were country fried
accents and I later got a coach a voice
coach and but it was like wwtn we're
talking Nashville y'all call in y'all
gain money questions it was hillbilly
redneck radio I remember being little
and driving through downtown Nashville
with the and the billboard started going
up yeah you had a milk mustache yep it
was like
milk it was like all over Nashville
there was a campaign called got milk it
was popular yes 30 years ago and um all
these celebrities with their milk
mustache and it was kind of a passive
Progressive question got milk and so we
said got debt and put milk mustaches on
and the scissors and all of it it's
great good imagery though was this back
in money game days it was a money game
from day one that's what it was called
when did it transition to the Dave
Ramsey Show
um
we had uh started syndicating the show
and the guy that was on with me left
and there was another guy working on
Fridays who uh they fired him the radio
station wouldn't let him keep going
because he started doing politics stuff
um and so I end up last man standing
doing the show and we were trying to
Syndicate it doing marketing nationally
with the money game the money game the
money in the game the money game and uh
Laura Schlesinger Dr Laura was blowing
up she was getting huge we had about 30
stations or 40 stations at the time and
Rush was of course huge and Sean was
blowing up Hannity was blowing up for
the first time
um and so you know we actually had a
great marketing guy there's a friend of
ours come in and go you're you know
you're killing me here Rush does not
have the political game Dr Lara does not
have the relationship game people are
having trouble figuring out there's too
many things going on with this brand you
need to just bring it to the Dave Ramsey
show you need to brand everything off of
Dave Ramsey we shifted everything today
Ramsey branding off the single person
brand and then everything drove through
that brand that and that focus is what
helped us move everything Events books
websites are working it was in the early
days of the web and
um this whole place was built on you and
your personality so what point did you
go okay this can't just be about me
forever we've got to bring in more
voices to carry this message at what
point did he start thinking about that
and taking action
about 15 years ago in my mid-40s I said
um you know this thing's not going to
outlive me if I if we don't decide how
we're going to carry the message in the
Next Generation and as we started
thinking about that we said well you
know we don't really say anything that's
unique
lots of people have said live on listen
you may get on a budget you know lots of
Articles were boring written by Boring
Financial people and the only thing
that's unique is that we actually love
the people we actually care about people
and we actually helping them and we've
got compassion for them and we're sassy
and smart Alec and funny and tell
stories and entertaining and convince
them in the midst of that to go through
their transformation so we realized at
that point that the business the whole
thing we built would just die with me
if we didn't have other people that
could do the same thing that could love
people well engage them be smart smart
alec loving compassionate whatever it
took bold whatever it took in the moment
to do not only good radio but be good on
stage be thought leaders in their space
and so we started with the idea of
bringing other people on and
you know we discussed uh
for a hot minute just it being Rachel
but the more we looked at that that
would be uh unfair to her to dump the
weight of the whole thing on one person
number one and then number two we
couldn't find anywhere where the single
follow-up the single brand following the
brand had worked which hardly couldn't
find any language that anything it
worked but God kind of spoke to us and
said you know
um it's a one-to-many handoff not a
one-to-one handoff and so that's how you
are here we sit thank you thank you guys
you're welcome you're really wimped out
heavy laser Crown yeah how do you how do
you guys sum up what the Ramsay show is
like if you're talking to a stranger on
the street and they're like What's the
Ramsay show how would you all describe
it I would say it's a place that people
call in with their questions about their
life and
it's more heavily geared towards money
um
but yeah it's just a couple people
sitting in in a radio
Studio friends and taking people's calls
I think there was a there's like a
Simplicity in mind if you remember I'm
gonna butcher it uh possibly but I think
many years ago this tagline of the show
was like where real life happens call
after callers I happen to call her after
caller and I I think even that's an
older moniker I think that's actually
still extremely relevant we're kind of
diving into whatever mess is going on
and you know life and going here's how
we think we can help well you know it
doesn't matter what the topic is that
caller is calling in in that moment
going I I need some help I mean if you
think about the dynamic for someone to
call into a live show we're all weird
you know we're a small sliver of the
population that doesn't freak out when
you're in front of people I mean most
people really do Fear public speaking
more than death and so the pressure for
someone to call in live on the air and
talk to somebody that's that's a
terrifying proposition for a lot of
people so there's that
and then they're dealing with something
where they go I this is I I feel like I
need a breakthrough and so regardless of
the topic like Rachel said it's just
real a real person with a real struggle
who needs real help I I remember the
first couple of calls I took on my
podcast and it came out organically my
first my first response to their
question was why are you calling me and
like that's a huge thing why haven't you
called your friends or your pastor or
your family members and to a person
every response was
dude I got nobody yeah like you're the
only person to call and so if you had
asked me right when I was starting what
is the role of the show like how do I
explain it I would say it's a show
people call that life now I've I think
my answer would be different it's we'll
be there it's a call we when when you've
got nobody we'll be honest with you and
we'll tell you what we think and we we
think we're pretty smart we think we
know what we're talking about but we'll
be honest with you and I think that
there's a lack of
people who will be honest with you and
not try to play some games with you and
just say here's what I would do in your
situation and I think we're just missing
that yeah I also think it's just like a
safe space like these topics we talk
about sometimes there's stigma around
them people feel shame and they feel
intimidated to talk to their friends and
family and it's like this is a spot
where we're comfortable with this like
you can bring us your ugly stuff you can
bring us the things that you don't want
to mention to anyone else and we'll work
through it we'll celebrate with you the
things no one else will celebrate well
that and the within the first 30 seconds
of most calls is okay how much money do
you make how much debt do you have and
like
you're not gonna explain just like tell
your BFF for that usually you're like
yeah it's kind of personal information
but I'll tell these strangers on the
phone because there's no and that's the
beauty I'm like there's no emotional
attachment to us in a sense because
we're like we're here so you call we'll
hear it all and I'll just you cut
through months
I remember when I was first seeing um
counseling clients in my practicum they
would tell me all kinds of things about
their intimate life about their
relationships what they failed at they
would not tell me how much they made
they wouldn't tell much debt they have
and it's so funny it's like hey my name
is Tom how much do you make and how much
debt you got I mean we're like right
through that man and we've changed
people's names how much of that's credit
card debt Tom exactly it's like super
like you failed and let's just lay it
all out but I mean I think there's a
level of the world is desperate for that
and you don't get it anywhere else
because there's we've got to do 17
sessions in therapy to get to even get
to that question we've got to establish
trust you called us what's the problem
Dave you built a trust brand do you you
know I don't take get for granted that
people call in and trust us with their
Life's greatest problems is that
something you were intentional about
from day one
or did it you kind of go oh people trust
me I got to make sure I handle this well
you know we started out just answering
the technical question day one and then
we started realizing
late they
really are opening up
and letting us into the intimate parts
of their life
um and then they you know they would
call randomly about some marriage thing
or something I'm like I okay I can help
you with your 401k what are you doing
and but it started just you know what we
used to call Uncle Dave or Papa Dave
started kind of evolving pretty early
even though I was young but it was just
this trusted friend that was wise and
that would you know that seemed to have
just some common sense about life and
um we started realizing that that was
there and what that is then is a tool to
actually be able to help them because
they're not going to take any advice if
they don't trust you right but I mean
and if you violate that trust if you uh
when you win we violate we all goof up
yeah when we when we mess up uh even the
smallest of things we don't you know
sometimes we're compassionate when we
should be a little tougher sometimes
we're too tough when we should have been
a little more compassionate
and um you messed up you mess up the
connectivity and the audience all knows
that I mean it's not just the caller
that gets that message so then it's a
little harder to trust next time so uh
but but most of the time the audience
has been uh really forgiving
and um at least portions of it the
portions that aren't forgiving are gone
so but the uh they're listening to
something else but uh you know they they
this you know these people are trying to
help because on my walk this morning
construction worker my neighborhood stop
he goes hey man I'm a millennial I
listen to every day I love your stuff
man you're changing lives man you
changed my life thanks so much and I'm
like dude you changed your life I didn't
change your life but I mean that guy's
out there and he's listening to when I
talk to someone else he'll never be a
caller
but great guy yeah but he'll never be a
caller so that trust is built on
consistency over time if you're not
wavering in your opinion Dave for better
and for worse so talk about some of the
foundational principles that run
throughout the show
uh
it all kind of falls under the umbrella
of being not conformed to this world
but be transformed
by the renewing of your mind and so we
can look out there in any Department
compartment of our lives in society
marriage parenting mental health career
money
you name it at business ethics
leadership we can look into any area out
there and see the vast majority of
people in that segment are dysfunctional
they're struggling
because and so you don't want to be
normal in almost any of those categories
I just mentioned you you want to be
unusual and success is unusual so it's
why we say it's probably looking to
smile when we say that person's
successful they have a successful
marriage and because it's unusual you
know and so uh the underlying principle
is to lead them away from
the dysfunctional normal
to the functional abnormal
in whatever area it is and that's just
truth telling and again compassion and
boldness and uh
laughter and stories and tears and
then people trust you and then you can
take them by the hand and lead them to
the next place they need to go in all of
those areas so that's kind of the
underpinning underneath all the
different topics from money and life and
relationships Rachel you've been in the
money space for you know a decade now
here at Ramsey as a personality what
have you found the common threads the
principles that carry regardless of the
calls
well from the money angle I would say
those underlying principles are
teaching people to live unless they make
which means getting out of debt staying
out of debt having margin in your life
which frees you up in so many other
areas when you have margin in your bank
account
you have the rainy day funds like that
like those were those are kind of the
tried and true and it's funny because
it's so simple right like that's what
that's what makes me laugh about even
the mind-blowing money advice right I
know that's what's wrong with the show
is like it's 30 years of kind of from
from especially the financial
perspective the money perspective
it's the same stuff over and over and
over and over and over and over and
still you'll get people that are like oh
you were so wise I'll never forget one
of my first national hits I was in New
York City doing one of the morning shows
the on set we were doing the live
segment and I and I made the comment
yeah just you know you have to live on
less than you make because it's
something I've heard my whole life it's
what we say here at Rooms all the time
it's just like a and they and these
people that I've watched on like these
these anchors on the show that I very
much look up to in life because I'm like
oh or not look up to but just I I
watched them in my own house
they looked at me and one of them said
that is so smart
[Laughter]
yeah so I think for us too like those
were doomed
ay Jesus is coming
though right like to his point
when you're conformed to the world or
doing what the world is doing and
they're not like on something so simple
with live unless you make so that's
always the bright spot where I'm like we
can we can insert hope into the culture
and it's not confusing like we know what
I mean like we get to bring out a very
simple plan and we get to talk about
Behavior change and the things that make
it difficult but that's what I love
about all the principles is I'm like
there's not many and they're pretty
simple pretty simple to understand hard
to do sometimes but one of the things we
do in one of the in all the areas is we
take the complex and make it reachable
I'll tell people in our marketing team
or on-air people all the time same thing
put the cookies on a shelf where
everyone can reach the cookies
because in the mental health field we
like to
speak over Financial people like to
speak over career coaches they want to
use seventy thousand dollar words when a
when a two dollar word would have done
the job but it's all in an effort to
look smarter feel smarter build
themselves up rather than communicate
connect and help someone where they are
and so in that sense we get the joy of
just being regular Folk who just happen
you know we don't have to be hotty toddy
we don't have to be you know better than
uh because Financial people do this a
lot in the you know in that world and
we're just not those people we're just
may or may not like us or you may not or
may not agree with us but what we say to
the same simple oh he's doable and it's
life-changing I think that's part of the
reason it's the second largest Talk
Radio Show in America it just connects
with every American out there we're not
using Big Ten Dollar words like you're
saying we try to keep it really simple
and John you've got two phds that's got
to be especially difficult for you to
bring the cookies
one thing that that I think Dave taught
me real early was
I've got like they've got success he's
got his name on a building
um he's got a a nice car right a nice
house
and
um him and his wife still disagree on
things and he's got Reckless children
right that's still gone off the frontier
let's get off the rails
um not just his wife disagrees with him
oh geez we can't have a family session
break out but like I I think there's
something about
a here's the right steps and it's hard
and then I'm going to go first and I
think that's missing from popular
culture and popular media is if I can
just get to this place then everything's
perfect and everything works out and I
can't identify with that I can't
identify the marriage that nobody has
any problems I can't identify with I'm
out of debt and I'm still gonna have a
disagreement with my spouse so because I
want to buy I want to buy that new
guitar so bad and she's like we don't
need another one you don't even play in
a band like I know but I need that like
I want to know that someone's still
having that disagreement or like I want
this new car
we've got you're good on Cars nope I
need this one too right
now I can relate to that and I think
there's a human there's a human element
that's like oh that guy's just like me
yeah right our bank accounts may look
different our business may look
different but that dude's just like me
and I'll follow that guy right this may
sound silly but it's like whenever I'm
talking and I'm thinking through how can
we translate the data and the content
it's like if I were listening to this
would I get bored like would I zone out
and just kind of tune out and if if
that's the case then it's like okay we
gotta bring this down we gotta make this
more relatable because it's like I mean
when I'm reading content that's like way
up here and heady it's like oh they
sound smart but like this is boring yeah
and what am I going to do with it what
am I going to do with it how do I apply
this to my life it doesn't matter to me
totally totally
that happened to me once on the air
sorry what was it this girl called and
finally
okay Sarah where did you get all these
numbers and it just goes silent she goes
out of my butt
[Applause]